it's great to be joined today by Daniel
Cohen who's a professor of economics and
founding member of the Paris School of
Economics his latest book is the
infinite desire for growth Daniel it
seems to me that conceptually the idea
of this infinite desire for growth in
some way is premise on a world that has
to some degree finite resources is that
a consideration that sort of seems
missing from our thoughts about how we
conceive of our economic system and
things like the stock market and future
investments isn't it all sort of based
on the idea that there can be growth
indefinitely on a planet of limited
resources I think this is certainly a
part of the of the South that people
need to have that is we are certainly in
a world with finite resources and and we
need to think a deeper but you know why
is it that that our desire for growth is
so large I think this is also this is
certainly part of what I have in mine
and I have a full chapter on the
ecological limits to it my my own
question is really to try to understand
why is it that we are so much in need
for growth and whether this is something
of a new phenomenon you know it's very
frequent to hear from the economy that
economic growth is something very recent
that started you know with the
Industrial Revolution of the 18th and
19th century so if that is the case you
know why is it that so suddenly we need
growth infinitely when when we lived for
such a long time without it so that
that's part of what's driving my my my
thoughts and my book is the need for
growth possibly just necessary to
validate the capitalist system in other
words if if we had agreement from you
know idea agenda setter so to speak that
may be indefinite or infinite growth is
not the goal wouldn't that call into
question how society is organized that
the basic economic
in capitalist countries no I absolutely
want to focus and zoom on that kind of
question but I think that capitalism
alone would not have brought this his
desire for growth if it was not
fulfilling something for ourselves and
so sort of of point of equilibrium
between supply capitalism and demand and
I'm interested as a starter from by by
this question of why is it that we
ourselves you know she's so sorry when
growth disappear and somehow ask for
more and I think you know one of the
foundation of this is is is really part
of the democratic revolution that is in
the democratic revolution we all feel
that we are equal and and that is not
the case we're not equal there's a lot
of inequality in the world and and
growth is a way of offering the promise
that although you you are not equal to
say your manager you will still reach
some basket of consumption goods
sometimes later in the future so
typically that worked very well in the
50s and in the 60s where only the
richest had a car but still you knew
that in 10 or 15 years you as a worker
would have won and that was somehow the
beauty of capitalism which was that it
allowed a very unequal society to offer
a way of fulfilled fulfillment of this
democratic ideal and the reason why
today's is become much more you know
problematic why there is so much crisis
and why I think in part there is the
right of populism everywhere in the
world is that this promise is not
fulfilled anymore and something got
broken in the 80s and 90s by which you
could not
say anymore to worker you know you're
poorer than I am me your manager but but
wait on you you will get access to the
same basket of good in the future so
that's the rise of inequalities which is
another phenomena that I'm trying to
describe but I think that it goes beyond
the sheer question of income it's really
in the work that you have you feel
betrayed by the promise of belonging to
the same world and and I think again
this is why we need growth as a solution
to a problem that we cannot solve which
is widely that we cannot offer as we did
for the middle class see sense of
solidarity which brought which was
brought by growth but I think not only
by growth but also by the feeling that
society as a whole was sort of United
I'm curious about you know what might
underlie you're not you're not a
psychologist but the sort of
psychological component of this desire
yeah I'm familiar with I don't have an
exact quote in front of me but during
the 20th century John Maynard Keynes had
this idea that at some point in the
future technology would allow basically
for the basic basket of goods that the
average person needs to be provided with
less than a full-time job people could
be spending 15 or 20 hours a week
working and otherwise they would have
more time to devote to leisure or
personal development and of course it's
hilarious to think now that that's what
technology would have allowed right
technology has been used to increase the
productivity of the individual worker
but to basically keep the workload the
same or higher and I'm curious to what
do you attribute that and what do you
think is the psychological component to
it I think you know for the economy's
there is a you know one important clock
there a person could reach out
Easterling and and and and and he has
you know written a number of papers
which are known in the literature as the
history in products and and this is very
important because a Kinsey Easterling
paradox exactly allows us to understand
the question that you asked
ken's indeed the 30 said by 2020
basically we'll work a couple of hours a
day in order to satisfy what he called
the old atom in us but basically we'll
move to something else we'll have we
shall have moved to post materialist
society and and and and it's exactly
coincidently what Marx also said in the
19th century that there would be a
moment that you would call communism in
which you know you would just get what
you need without having to work too much
and and that would be the Bliss point of
history the end of history really for
him and this thing as has been entirely
defeated people are never satisfied they
want more income you see typically in a
country like France we are about twice
richer that than we were 50 years ago at
the famous time of of May 68 that we are
celebrating right now and in May 68 it
was exactly you know the criticism by
the students and the youth in May 68 was
exactly based upon what you said that is
that that was let's move away from this
materialistic society we have enough we
don't need to continue on that path
the famous thinker called Marcus about
Marcus who wrote another unit the one
dimensional men and arrows and
civilization really made this prognostic
this provision that we would you move to
something else because we had enough and
we never had enough and and the
explanation that is given by Easter
linen and the people work with him is
essentially that we are social beings
and and and that we compare ourselves
continuously to what the others are so
it's not a question of being rich in
absolute term it's always really
relative so if I see that my neighbor is
having more than I have I want to work
other in order to get the same thing as
my neighbor there's been a lot of
psychological tests that confirm that
but one thing that I like very much is
is an anecdote which
through data which is that when two
sisters are married to
two men one of one of which is richer
than the other one the the the woman who
is married to the poorest man works more
than her sister because she needs to
compensate for the fact that her husband
is poorer obviously this could be
resulted in men and female in the other
in the other sense and that's a sin that
there is a continuous rivalry and and
again I get back to Tocqueville who put
that as the essence of the democratic
society Tocqueville was you know somehow
critical of of some of the consequences
of the democratic society which which is
that II said democracy obviously is good
and we all cherish it but one of the
intended consequences of democracy that
you will be in competition one with the
other there is nothing that should
prevent you to get when the other guy is
doing but obviously and this is the
point that you were raising if we could
just clap our air and say you know let
maybe let's grow less let let's try to
be less demanding in terms of economic
growth there is if you follow this line
of reasoning a possibility to work less
and to be as satisfied as you were
before to the extent that your degree of
satisfaction is always relative but that
would take an immense degree of
coordination and cooperation which is
very hard to achieve in France for
instance in in the 1990s it was 35 hours
decree which sort of imposed on everyone
to work only 35 hours we based upon
exactly this idea this is every if
everyone is working 35 hours then you
don't get richer than the other one but
it didn't work because you know it was a
temptation to work a little bit less
more than the other than Indiana Japan
rather so there is a need for a change
of mentality if you want to proceed
along those lines and that get me back
to the ecological system you know the
ecological question that you that you
raised at the very beginning we know
that we live in the world of finite
resources and maybe that could be you
know the way by which we we are somehow
obliged to think differently about
economic growth and that could be the
catalyst for another way of thinking
about about wealth and and perhaps we
could you know we could we could sort of
you know loosen a bit the kind of
rivalry that we have to be always richer
than the neighbors and get into
something better more qualitative but
it's a it's a quantitative change of
mind that is needed in order to achieve
that Daniel the book is fascinating
we've been speaking about Daniel Cohen's
book the infinite desire for growth
Daniel's a professor of economics and
founding member of the Paris School of
Economics thank you so much for talking
to me about this thank you